about matrix multiplication and Virginia
and Josh jointly going to present it up
so thanks thanks for buggy thanks for
inviting me so I have a bit of a cold
and I think or something so I might be
coughing out try to refrain from
covering but Josh has been gracious
enough as the second expert on this
topic to give the second half of the
talk so let's begin so this is talked
about my one of my favorite problems
matrix multiplication for a long time we
try to improve on the running time for
this problem and unfortunately like
there seem to be diminishing returns and
we try to understand why this is the
case and this is what this talk is about
okay so let me introduce the problem to
you although I'm sure all of you know it
what is it's about so you have two n by
n matrices and you want to compute their
product in particular this is a bilinear
form when you're just evaluating it over
some input and here we will assume
they're agentic circuit model let's
assume all the entries of the matrices
or let's say complex numbers so in
general there's some field and we count
the number of operations we take to
compute this by linear form and the
operations are additions multiplications
divisions over the field
ok and we'll assume each of these
operations like takes constant time and
we're just yeah we worry about the
asymptotics
so clearly the naive algorithm just
follows the definition and you can
definitely compute the product of two n
by n matrices in length cubed time and a
big breakthrough was by Strauss and who
showed that actually can do it faster
and then to the 2.81 time and then there
was a lot of improvements which I'll
talk a little bit about in a little bit
in a little while and then this
culminated in the current best running
time which is something like n to the
two point three seven to nine then
and probably can improve a little bit
more someone the decimal places over
here if you're working a little harder
but you know we have other things to do
so we can define Omega which is the
matrix with multiplication exponent
we're defining a little bit more
formally and a little bit and for now
just say Omega is the smallest real
number for which you can multiply and by
n matrices and then to do Omega plus
little of one time and of course by from
here we get the room I gave it mostly
stuff ok so the big open question is is
Omega equal to 2 in other words can we
multiply two matrices and roughly linear
time in their input why should we even
believe that well we don't have any
lower bounds that tell us the otherwise
but you know why should we believe it
should be a magical still may be no
throughout the last decade that I've
been thinking about this problem now I
think it's Omega is bigger than 2 so you
know alright so I will give you a very
high level overview of matrix
multiplication algorithms to date and I
will kind of narrow and on this view and
they will generalize it
so so there's two components to any
matrix multiplication algorithm nowadays
first you come up with some identity
which tells you that some tri linear
form which I'll define a little bit it
can be computed very efficiently and
then there's a second component which is
a method to embed our favorite form
matrix multiplication into the this
efficiently computable one in some way
and we'll narrow in on what I mean over
here this is a very high-level view and
then if you apply this method to this
trilling your form that you understand
you get a matrix multiplication
algorithm so there's roughly two
approaches which can yield the current
best bound on matrix multiplication
algorithms the first one is the stress
and slash coppersmith Winograd approach
where m is the so-called laser method
which I'll briefly explain later on and
this method works very well on some very
structured types of tensors and they and
the current best record from Omega is
given by this coppers and Winograd
tensor which I'll show you later on the
second type of approach which can give
roughly the same burns is the so called
group theory and approach which was
started by Conan umas and the method is
the group theoretic method and the
tensor that one uses is basically you
take some very structured group and you
define the structure of tensor of its
group algebra and this is the tensor you
use and there's various methods to come
up with the identity for these tensors
and then the method is very nice and
beautiful
so a very rough view of what we have so
there's these two methods that we yield
the current best bounds on Omega and now
what we do the first thing we do in our
work is we generalize them so first we
define several methods over here they're
all subsumed both of these so the first
one we arbitrarily called the solar
method because you know Strassen called
this pretty much arbitrarily the laser
method so we reserve the right to
continue the tradition so okay so this
is a solar method you reach the Sun then
you have the Galactic method you got
some other galaxy the universal method
is basically the dream approach that
subsumes all of these and I want to
point out that while these are very nice
methods and we know how to use them to
analyze particular sensors these ones
the generalizations there's we don't
have any way right now to get the best
implementation of these methods they're
just dream methods out there you know I
will define them in a second okay so
there so there was some prior work on
limitations of these methods over here
for the laser method there was work by
unbiased film assimil ago who showed
that you cannot prove that Omega equals
two if you restrict yourself to the
coppersmith Winograd tensor which is the
current best record holder and you use
exactly the implementation of the laser
method that has been using and the work
so far so in particular there's a
particular constant is much bigger than
two for which you cannot go beyond with
these methods so here are not really
like the best is like at five and
there's a best lower bounds for Q equals
five which is also the current best
upper bound but still it's like it's
quite restricted to these particular
methods of analyzing tensors yeah
laser method and authority committed are
different so they analyze different
tensors so ultimately these approaches
all of these approaches they are only
for analyzing a fixed type of tensor
that you're working with and if you
change the tensor there'll be the same
method like I can always apply all these
methods to the matrix multiplication
tensor apply and so they'll be the same
but because they're analyzing different
methods they are different they are
subsumed by this one as well see later
sorry some people penalty and a similar
method using - okay so he said that some
people claim you can simulate the laser
method using the group theoretic matter
this is kind of true so in a sense like
the coppers and Winograd tensor you can
find a related tensor that gives the
same Omega and you can embed it in a
group Theory tensor and yes you can
simulate it but that doesn't mean you
know you're analyzing this tensor
exactly and so on so it is some sense it
could be true but it's not formally true
that even try to give the same bound and
so the reason why they give the same
down is because you can exactly why
because because you can change this to a
slightly related things are embedded
into a group tensor use them
okay all right so now so we had this but
it was restricted to these types of
methods now over here it's also known
that if you pick a particular any fixed
group and you apply the group theoretic
method you also not give - now this was
by blessing ik corn Church Groeschel
Oman's
sarin and one more person and I wrote it
down I'm sorry
now slide that's it this I'm gonna
elaborate on this so now you could take
some group and analyze it and it's
tensor powers okay and then you will not
get to make it close to but you can have
groups that are parametrized by
something like the symmetric group on n
elements right and then this this would
this limitation would not apply to like
the methods where you analyze the
symmetric group how well it would do for
matrix multiplication and then you pick
the best end so this would not you might
still get to make a question there so
fixed group just means you pick a group
that's not parameterize by anything and
potentially just uses tensor powers but
not but not some parameterizing family
of groups that you could analyze so it's
a little limited but still says
something how limitation on this okay so
what do we do so we take this vast
generalization of these methods and we
say that even this method applied to the
coppersmith Winograd tensor for any Q I
will not give it Omega cos to in
particular there is a fixed constant
something like two point zero zero one
or something that you can now build go
below no matter what Q you get even if
you take Q it goes to infinity and also
the same sort of fixed group thing here
also applies to this method so you
cannot get on my goop equals to four
fixed groups and their tensor powers
then sort of order group but then there
is a way to analyze it and so that's
right we'll get into this now this is a
very high level of what's going on now
and I'm going to narrow and define a
bunch of stuff you know you know yeah
yeah the telling of it
you've analyzed anyone's protect for
just the ones that it was that's right
yes
so we yes so let me let me get into it
so get into the details of
yes you can
you could doing particularly with the
matrix multiplication 10 sake yes yes
absolutely absolutely so the universal
method could be used with these tensors
except that now we have some proofs the
showed that this also is not true but
josh is coming up with more and more
techniques and verifying them so okay
sorry okay so let me just give some
basic definitions so I can give you more
of more of an idea of what we're saying
here okay so in this talk know define
tensors as the following try linear form
so you have these three sets of
variables x1 to xn why I want to Lyon as
you want to repeat the formal variables
and a tensor will define as a tri linear
form where you get these coefficients t
IJ K would have multiplied X I YJ ZK all
right you can think of the t's t IJ case
as coming from an underlying field like
the complex okay and now that we have
this we can define a rank 1 tensor as a
product of linear combinations of the X
variables Y variable Z variables so this
is a rank 1 tensor and now just like
what matrices the rank of a tensor is
the minimum number of Rank 1 tensors
whose sum equals the tense all right if
you are not comfortable try linear forms
you can think of the usual definition of
a tensor is belonging to C n turns your
CMC tells you CP or alternatively for
the rank want answers there just eight
else would be
all right so what is the matrix
multiplication tensor well it's written
like this the M M by M matrix
multiplication is mmm and it's the sum
over X IJ YJ k zi k basically has a 1
only in front of these products and as
an intuition the coefficient of the Zi k
entry is exactly the product of the I
drove and the J's column of the legacy
so this is why it defines matrix
equation
alright and something you've seen before
when you know teaching or learning about
strassens algorithm is that if we know
that the rank of the M by M matrix
multiplication tensor is let's say K
like for 2 by 2 and 7 then we can get a
recursive algorithm for n by n matrix
multiplication just by blocking so you
take here and by n matrices you block
them into M by M blocks each of size n
over m by n over m then you use your
identity that comes from the rank
expression over here to can't form these
linear combinations of the blocks and
luckily for us linear combinations just
involve summing matrices which is linear
time in the sum of the number of entries
and and then you perform products of
these blocks using the recursive
approach and then you use the rank
expression again to assemble the final
product by yeah getting them so then you
get this recursive running time T of n
is K times T of n over n plus order N
squared so as long as K is a little
smaller than n cube just so you get
something so cute all right so then you
get that from a right expression you get
an Omega upper bound of log base M of K
all right so this is just the basics so
now we can go this is just a recap
then we can define Omega adjust the
women over m of log m of the rank of M
by M matrix multiplication and it could
say matrix multiplication takes until
you make it up all right so now this
motivates the goal of getting upper
bounds for matrix multiplication tensors
for fixed dimension so for two-by-two
we know the rank is at no 7 in fact it's
exactly 7 and so you get shots and bound
then for 70 by 70 pan gave this
monstrous upper bound which still gives
something better than stresses and you
can try even more and more however these
matrices get unwieldly it's very
difficult to bound their rank and in
fact even for 3x3 matrix multiplication
we don't know the best ranked out so
this motivates the next approach which
means instead of just fixing some fixed
size matrix multiplication tells you
pick some other types that we want to
understand so here's the next approach
we take yeah it was just maybe some
tentative or higher I mean simpler but
of course these are very structured
tensors it's not like we're working very
hard once but but it's still very
difficult to to analyze it in if you
even know when you define the search
space and you get rid of all the
symmetries even for 3x3 the search space
is enormous we don't have a good way to
analyze I know it's just stuff
okay so what we do instead is we take
ten sir that may not be a matrix
multiplication tensor and some tensor
for which whose rank we really know for
example this is one reason why the group
tensors are so nice because we we can
get their their ranks very easily so
they follow from Group C from
representations here in particular so
and then after we have a tensor whose
rank is very nice and small then we
tried to show that T contains a large
matrix multiplication tensor what is
this contained well if this containment
does not increase the rank of the
underlying tensor then you would you
would get the rank of M by M matrix
multiplication is bounded by the rank of
the tensor and then you couldn't apply
the previous approach just as before of
course this has this issue that now we
have to understand the ranks of these
two big tensors and so it's still not as
nice because of this we instead will
work with tensor products and
particularly the Kronecker product
tensors what is this so you have let's
say I have two tensors a and B they're
true linear forms over variables X Y Z
and X prime Y prime Z Prime and we can
define a new tensor which is their
tensor product the corner product which
is just you take okay so you you
basically what you take all the triples
ijk and I prime J prime K Prime and you
take a ijk times bi prime J prime Cooper
and then the variables are just pairs of
the original variables and the sum is
over all pairs and you can just think of
like a and B is polynomials you multiply
them and then you replace their variable
sets with new variables like we could it
corresponds to pairs so this is the
Kronecker product but what's nice about
this conical products he thinks that a
product of a of a by a matrix of
application and P by P is exactly a B
the a B by a
matrix multiplication this is just
follows by blocking and also we have
this nice property that we really like
is that tensor rank is some
multiplication and ER this product so
it's nice so now it gives us this new
approach Oh before us so now instead of
just multiplying you can take powers of
a tensor what's the power
well you just multiply the tensor by
itself let's say n times and it gives
you the nth power
this gives you a tensor over whose
variables are just indexed by sequences
of the original indices so we have a
bunch of variables and also the rank of
death power is at most the nth power of
the rank but actually what's nice is
that actually the rank of the tensor
power can drop significantly in the
exponent
for example if you take two by two
matrix multiplication we know it's rank
is seven however if we take out the nth
power it's much small smaller than 7 to
the N because as we know Omega is much
less than two point eight one so we have
this nice thing and if this motivates
defining the asymptotic rank of a tensor
so there's some tonic rank is you take
the nth power take the rank of damaged
power of the tensor you take the and
fruit and now look at how these girls
you know that it's at most the rank of
the original tensor but it can be much
smaller and in fact we can use this the
synthetic ranking and place of the rank
in our approach it will give you better
bounds so now again as I said you can
get to make a bouncing Omega using
doesn't talk to crank is to the right so
now we can do this the following
refinement of the approach you start
with a density that's not necessarily
matrix multiplication you show that it
has small asymptotic rank some in some
way then you take some huge tensor power
event of it and analyze it with some
nice take
NIC's and you show the distance your
power contains some large matrix
multiplication tensor where the
dimension of the tensor depends on N and
you could take n to infinity and do
stuff and then you get some very nice
bounds and now let's very talk about
what containment means so containment we
want that if it contains B then the
asymptotic rank of a is at least
asymptotic rank of G okay and as from
our previous slide we know that if this
holds then and
tensor power contains this matrix
multiplication tensor then we're
actually bounding the synthetic rank of
M by M matrix multiplication and we
bound Omega okay
and now we get to this containment
notion there's we define three different
options of increasing strengths so first
one which are defined on the next slide
is zeroing out the second is would call
monomial degeneration the third one is
just the generation arbitrary choice and
each is subsumed by the one below it
automatic simplification terms of um yes
yeah I mean that this is actually kind
this is what we want we want to bomb
them as I'm target practice to get to
Omega okay so all right I want to is on
the side I want to actually say
something that instead of containing a
single matrix multiplication tensor by a
theorem of sugar gay we know that
actually it's okay to for the tensor
power to contain a bunch of matrix
multiplication tensors that do not share
any variables so and this will also give
you a bound on Omega via this asymptotic
rank inequality I should hug it but and
then it gives you this other this more
general approach which is your show that
T has smallest entire crank and then you
showed that the tensor that sensor power
contains many big independent matrix
multiplication tensors where many AM big
depend on n and offense okay but for the
purposes of this talk so I don't keep
writing
direct songs I'm going to ignore this
but keep in mind that everything I say
actually applies there so forget about
this so now let's define zeroing out so
let's say I take tensor a and tensor B
and I'll define what it means that B is
a zeroing out of a so B is a zeroing out
from a if you can get B by removing all
occurrences of some variables in a so
you just set them to zero so for example
let's say I take this tensor over here
and I can get ten of the tensor B by
setting the variable y1 to 0 and this
will remove this triple and this trip
that's what zeroing out means so I get
all of these and note you so when you do
this you will get some sub tensor of the
previous one but you cannot get any put
to any one that you want
yeah in terms of like a
three-dimensional representation of the
desert this is same as like removing one
for you yes yes you just remove you move
some plane so you can you can pick any
sets of variables and remove them so you
remove a bunch of planes and and you'll
get on your tensor so I want to point
out that this if you take the first
three sums over here you cannot zero out
a to C because this term over here
shares a variable with every single one
of these so we cannot zero this thing
out without zeroing out one of these and
because of this we will see soon there
if we take the next version of
containment monomial degeneration you
can get to see
so actually monomial degeneration is a
strictly stronger than zero okay so now
another thing that's very very easy to
see is that if a zeroes out to be then
the rank of a is at least the rank of B
which is what we wanted
you basically just take the original
ranked expression and get rid of the
variables that you donate okay so this
is good this is the simplest thing and
in fact this is all out of what all our
approaches do actually deserving out
okay next I'll define degeneration now
just back to the point so you think the
periodic methods as well as the laser
method was doing this absolutely both
the group - Arika method and the copper
so in the grand method they both choose
your own and do not go to the further
yes any questions but is it true that if
the rank of a is bigger than B then the
asymptotic ranks also the same so in
this case it's true I can also put us
into power of a through of L matrix is
zero now these weeks of the tensor power
yes yeah yeah yes so okay so now the
degeneration is a little bit Messier so
let me define it imagine we have two
tensors over different sets of variables
a is over X Y Z and B is over X prime Y
prime Z prime right so to get from A to
B what we do is we take the variables of
a and replace them with linear
combinations of the variables of B where
these linear the coefficients in the
linear combinations are polynomials and
some indeterminate Epsilon
so in other words you can take matrices
P Q and R that take the variables K
basically the K prime by K matrix so
that they take the XYZ variables to X
prime Y prime Z variables and the
entries of these matrices are
polynomials over Epsilon and then you
can write this thing so applying these
transformations to the tensor a will
give you some expressions whose
coefficients are very polynomials in
Epsilon
so if you take the term
the terms that have the smallest powers
of epsilon s coefficients and they give
you exactly B then these are the
generation of a this big ol thing gets
rid of terms that are multiplied by the
powers of epsilon that are bigger than
the smallest term and I'll give you an
example in a second this is a
degeneration yes
so border rank gives is you use the
generation to get bored right yeah you
did you to generate to an independent
tensor the depends on 2 january thing
all right so so intuitively what happens
here is if you take you divide this this
transformation you go here by 1 over
epsilon to the age where this is the
smallest power and you take capsule on
to go to infinity all these terms will
go away and you'll get exactly B so you
will have a sequence of tensors that
converts to B and by theorem of by beany
if a degenerates to B then the
asymptotic rank of a is at least
asymptotic rank of B and this comes to
obvious question that's very boy there
was a camp out bordering so you're
saying that this is a more powerful
operation than zeroing out yes many
previous results used to be about the
border right rather than about the rank
itself
yeah so the thing is that border so I'm
not defining boring but if you take
tensor powers for the rank is like right
so it doesn't actually matter and for us
we're analyzing big tensor powers and
actually everybody uses shown Hargis
theorem and showed you on August theorem
is about zeroing ounces so we don't
actually is this for power here
this can dominate Brazilian art yes I
mean if you just put epsilon in front of
the variables that you want to zero out
that's what I'm gonna say now yes so let
me let me do this so first of all let me
define monomial degeneration in monomial
degeneration it says the generation in
which the these the entries of P Q and R
adjustment all males of epsilon so
they're not arbitrary promise okay one
over seven times epsilon to the ten so
let me give you an example monomial
degeneration and I'll get back to what
the Russell said so monomial
degeneration example very simple example
we take our original tensor and now
degenerated to this tensor see we're
zeroing out was not possible so what we
do is we multiply X 0 y1 and z1 by
epsilon and what happens then is you get
everything except for x1 y1 z1 gets a
power of epsilon that just want the
first power
but this one gets two it gets epsilon
squared because it contains both y1 and
z1 and because of this this is exactly
this tensor see and so we get that ade
actually went underneath to generalize
to see and you can get some examples
where you can degenerate but you cannot
monomial to generate and if you cannot
see so these are increasing powers of
embeddings of tensors that do not
increase the rank okay so now back to
Russell's question if you can zero out
to see
you can also monomial degenerate because
every time everything that he was 0 out
you just multiplied by epsilon and you
get this exactly what you want basically
all the 0 without variables will get
some power of epsilon in front of them
and all the other terms that don't have
zeroed out there those who have no he
will have just epsilon to the 0 okay so
good thank you
now we can say now the known approaches
are like this you take some tensor there
you really understand its asymptotic
rank it's tiny you take a self tensor
power you degenerate to some matrix
multiplication tensor and then you
combine these two methods to get the
bound on Omega and that the generation
you use can vary can be universal method
galactic and solar method what tensors
have been used Strawson use just the 2x2
matrix multiplication tensor itself and
then there were many many follow-ups
after that and then in 1986 Strassen
used a tensor there is not a matrix
multiplication tensor not some I cannot
join some of them and this is some funny
looking tensor here each of these is a
matrix multiplication tensors but they
share variables so it's pretty messy and
this is where you define the laser
method and then coppers win Winograd and
us and many people here we use this
tensor it's it's very structured
so just identity terms of n for
questions terms or actors just if we say
that the desert can be degenerated to
the multiplication right yes that's it
that's the definition of border so
questions like general generalization is
like equivalent to the equation of
things around which one up here this yes
this is that's why it's universal okay
so alright so I will just I'll take two
minutes and then you can take over so
the the first method the laser method
roughly what it does it takes these
tensors that are very nice in the sense
that they can be partitioned into things
that look like matrix multiplication
tensor for example the coppersmith
Winograd tensor is nice because if you
take this part this part this part and
this this and this they're all matrix
multiplication tensors in particular
each of these is either 1 1 Q or 1 Q 1
or Q 1 1
star means and each of these are what is
a 1 1 1 and what the method does is when
you take tensor powers of this tensor
here you just cleverly zero things out
so you get tensor powers of these little
tensors which are all matrix
multiplications and you do some stuff to
make them independent and then you get
exactly what you want you'll get that
you can use shown Hargis theorem and you
can use all the techniques that we have
but the whole point is that all the
methods out what this method does is
just use some basic combinatorics you
know sets excluding three Taylor
arithmetic progressions and really this
stuff to analyze what happens to this
tensor when you take tensor powers the
group theoretic method it was introduced
by Conan Romans and it works very nice
for these tensors the structure of
tensors of the group algebra zovut group
G and they're defined like this you take
the sum over all pairs of group elements
of X a X a Y BZ by a times B so you have
a one only when when the indus index of
z is eight times big all right so here's
a simple example very nice structured
tensor is e to and the nice thing is
that the rank border and Cassim tata
crank is very easily analyzed it's upper
bounded by the character degrees of the
group algebra so you can get a very nice
expression on that on that synthetic
rank and this just so if you you can use
your presentation theory to take the
tensor here and a presenters like block
tensors of matrix multiplication and
then and then the if you take the cure
to degrees you get the rank is upper
bound by the sum of the degree to the
Omega
resuming the dimension of the
globalization yes sorry yeah all right
so okay so then there's this oh if it if
your character degrees are d1 up to or
whatever decay will be upper bounded by
the sum over I of this abide to the
Omega nice back so then okay so then
this part is relatively nice because of
the nice structure of these tensors and
then common and omens that follow-up
works define some nice properties of
groups such as the triple product
practice property in simultaneous triple
product property and so on to give you
the 0 a 0 in out of the tensor or it
stands your powers to matrix
multiplication tensors and that that
that's the second part of the approach
but it's again only zeroing out alright
this part uses representation theory
this one just group to me all right so
now now it's time for a job to take over
and thanks
yeah
okay hello yeah so so I guess just to
recap what Virginia was saying these two
known approaches that we have for
getting the best known bounds on Omega
they they focus on particular nice
tensors like the laser method works for
tensors which have some structure like
the coppersmith Winograd tensor the
group theoretic method works for these
grouped group algebra tensors and they
both give ways to show that powers of
your tensor can zero out into big matrix
multiplication tensors but it's possible
that Biggers your matrix multiplication
tensors exist inside these tensors that
these methods don't find and for
instance I think we even believe that
they almost certainly do like the
improvements from coppersmith Winograd
paper to the more recent results can be
viewed as like slightly improving the
laser method to find slightly bigger
matrix Moulton sirs and then not to
mention you know if you move say two
monomials a generations maybe you can
find even big bigger matrix
multiplication tensors so so then our
result our results are limitations on
how big matrix multiplication tensors
you can actually find in powers of these
tensors so our first main result
Virginia I mentioned earlier is that
there's a universal constant C bigger
than two such that you can't get a
better bound on Omega than C using the
Galactic method these monomial D
generations applied to coppersmith you
wanna test grad tensors for any q and
then similarly we show for each finite
group g there's a constant bigger than
two such that you can't get better than
that constant using the Galactic method
applied to the group tensor yeah so just
a couple notes about these things
for the first theorem about the
coppersmith Winograd tensor oh i'll
actually I'm about to show you pretty
much the entire proof where you'll see
it actually only uses like a really
small amount of the structure of the
copper so through and the Grad tensor so
it applies to a lot of similar looking
tensors and i think probably like any
tensor where the laser method could
apply to it you can say something
musically
and then for theorem - yes of verging I
mentioned this but it's you get a
different constant figure than two for
each group so it actually doesn't rule
out trying to get Omega equals two by
finding a sequence of groups where this
constant approaches two and analyzing
the sequence of groups in the limit and
this kind of limitation is pretty well
understood in the among the people who
studied the group theoretic method I
guess and in fact there's this paper
from last year by will saw and where
which actually also implies our theorem
to result and in fact if I understand
correctly I think it even implies it for
the universal method for fixed groups
can't get oh so no fixed group can get
Omega equals to unit using the universal
method but still we don't know how to
rule out sequences of digitalization
yeah yeah yeah yeah galactic method
means monomial two generations yeah oh
yeah but yeah actually though the queue
for which our lower bound is worse is
like two equals twenty-five actually so
it's it's a bit bigger than the one for
which our upper bound is the best yeah
but it I think that might be just an
artifact of our analysis rather than
look back what the actual best or worst
view is
okay yeah so so the picture really looks
like this that we proved a lower bound
against the Galactic method for all of
these different tensors okay and then
the rest of the time I'm gonna show you
pretty much the entirety of our proof of
the lower bound for the coppersmith
through in a gret tensor it's like it's
I think it's relatively simple so I
should be able to explain almost
everything about it okay so our proof
technique is to go through something
called an independent tensor or a
diagonal tensor so this is just the Qi a
g''l tensor it's written with these
triangle braces Q it's just a tensor
with two terms that share no variables
with each other so it's like the analog
of the identity matrix and we're gonna
be really interested in the generations
from tensors two independent tensors so
for a tensor be I'll let I of B be the
biggest number Q such that there's a
degeneration from B to an independent
tensor of size Q and similarly tell we
had like ranked and asymptotic ranks we
want to look at like asymptotic I so let
I fill the talk all the asymptotics of
rank of P is the the max or the limb
soup overall end of I of power to the
power of 1 over N and yeah in fact
Strawson actually studied this
asymptotic sub break notation in a in a
line of work like 20 or 30 years ago
okay and similar to how we have these
three different methods for whether
you're using generations or monomial D
generations or ziering outs
we're similarly gonna have variants on
this eye for the three different methods
so alright I sub MD for the biggest few
that your tensor can monomials generate
into and then the asymptotic version of
this I'll call it the Galactic sub rank
of the tensor and similarly I Sub Zero
the biggest sensor you can zero out into
and I told as the solar sub rank of the
tensor in our paper we actually call
this the independence number of the
tester but I think solar suffering or
asymptotic solar subprimes might be a
better name for it
for the younger generation yeah yeah
yeah
I think galactic some prank sounds
cooler I don't so okay so why are we
interested in this a little spray some
nice properties of it so it's not hard
to see the zeroing out some ranks less
than or equal to the monomial
degeneration some rate plus we come up a
sub drink just because these different
notions are stronger and stronger it's
also not so hard to see that the
asymptotics of ranks less than or equal
to the asymptotic rank just because like
like a degeneration to an independent
tensor would give an asymptotic rank
upper bound for the independent tensor
and the tensor with two terms actually
has to have asymptotic rank you okay the
left one
no it's not it's a yeah it's it's not
very well understood but as far as we
know it's not equality yeah yeah yeah
that's right yeah we know examples are
there different yes there are between
the rightmost ones yes
so actually in our paper we show that
the leftmost ones are equal to each
other the zeroing out some rank is equal
to the monomial degeneration suffering
and if you've if you've seen like
Vinny's proof about why for drinks of
Isis for matrix multiplication the proof
of this is really similar to that okay
and one other like like simple
observation is that if B is over the X
variables lies areas of bulls and z
variables then the monomial degeneration
sub rank of B is that most the minimum
of the three sizes of the sets of
variables and this is just because
monomial degeneration always goes from
your tensor to a subset of the terms and
if you're getting independent terms at
the end you need at least one variable
for each of those terms okay so why are
we interested in this well there's a
really nice result that Strawson
actually proved
in the 80s that if you rewrite it in our
notation says that the matrix
multiplication tensor has its it's
monomial d-generation sub break is as
big as possible so I remember the M by M
by M matrix Moulton sir it has M Squared
X variables M Squared Y variables and M
Squared Z variables and in fact it's
it's absolute onic Galactic's of rank
asymptotic monomial degeneration some
rank is equal to M Squared so if you
have any tensor T and you're using it to
get a bound on Omega by monomial
degenerating it into a matrix Moulton
sir then you can compose this with
strawsons monomial degeneration to get
lower bound on the asymptotic Galactic's
of rank of the tensor T itself and in
particular if you wanted to use this
monomial degeneration from T to the
matrix motor to prove Omega equals 2
then you would also need it to be the
case that the asymptotic rank of T is
equal to M Squared so you will need
these two things to be equal to each
other and if you're working with like a
attention ascertain which is not
degenerate in some way so the asymptotic
rank is at least the number of variables
then this means if T is a tensor over K
different XYZ variables then it can
yield Omega equals to only if this
monomial degeneration I tilde is equal
to K and the more less than K it is the
better bound away from two you can prove
on what Omega you can yield using it and
so in order to prove our our lower
bounds on Omega that you can yield we're
gonna show upper bounds on this I tilde
of different tensors and if you can show
it's less than the number of variables
that means you get a lower bound on the
Omega you can get with it
so let me show you a sketch of how we do
that and the main idea is a nice limo we
prove that's about assigning a pop
probability distribution to the terms of
a tensor so here it is so while we show
is that if T is a tensor it has King
different variables of each type and
it's manila luzon generation I tilde is
equal to K then there's a probability
distribution eyes terms so way to assign
a probability to each term so they sum
to one and such that for each fixed
variable the sum of the probabilities
assigned to the terms containing that
variable is 1 in K so so there's a way
to assign a probability that each term
so that each variable is assigned to one
in K of the probability mass so let me
give you I'm not gonna give you the
whole proof of this vil let me give you
some intuition for a wife might be true
so if we were just looking at I instead
of I tilde so you take your tensor in
monowheel degenerate to an independent
tensor of size k then well this is just
a subset of the terms so we could assign
probability 1 in K to those terms and 0
to everything else and it would have
this property and then more generally
when you when you take a big tensor
powers you do a similar thing where
these probabilities are kind of like
it's the fraction of the time that you
pick that term in your like n tuples of
terms of the original tensor that's the
intuition for this yeah I think it's I
think it's very similar to that yeah in
fact maybe I'm not sure off the tongue
my head but maybe the same and then and
then yeah from here it's actually really
easy to see that the coppersmith you
Winograd tensor cannot have a
probability distribution like this oh
yeah so I'll call this P of X I just the
sum of the probabilities assign the
variable X I so here's the coppersmith
Winograd tensor again it has Q plus 2 of
each type of variable and I'm only going
to need to look at these last two terms
to show that it can't have this
distribution so if we look at the second
to last term here it's
the only turn on the tensor that has
wide q plus 1 in it so that means we
have to assign it probability 1 in Q
plus 2 similarly this last term it's the
only term in the whole tensor that is Z
Q plus 1 in it we have to assign it
probability 1 in Q plus 2 and this is
already a problem because both those
terms have X 0 in it so we've already
assigned too much probability mass to X
0
very simple to see you can't have this
type of probability distribution you
care about the second of those
conditions is that equality or less than
equal sorry
oh yeah it's it's yeah so so like when
it actually ends up being is if like
like the you look at the l1 distance
from the closest you can get to the
uniform distribution so actual uniform
distribution and then the ban on Omega
you gets just a function of that
distance but but as long as you can
bound it away from the uniform you bet
that means for this tensor you can't get
to okay yeah so if you're if you're
paying attention like I said I was gonna
show there's a universal constant
independent of 2 but actually this bound
I just showed it holds for all tube but
it sort of gets worse and worse that you
just larger like this only bounds the l1
distance a little bit askew gets quite
large and I mean there's some ways to
alter that argument but I'm now going to
show you a second maybe even simpler
argument that it only kicks in for large
enough Q but it gets better and better
at you sq gets larger and then the you
know the min overall Q of the max of
these two bounds is going to give our
constant see that I promise you okay so
so here it is we're gonna use one
another one other property of the
coppersmith Winograd tensor that we can
partition up its terms in this way into
we can partition up its terms into three
parts where the first part only has one
X variable the second part only has one
Y variable and the third part only has
one Z variable so in other words we're
using the fact that each term of the
coppersmith when a grad temps are either
has it has at least one of X 0 y 0 or Z
0 in it okay and in fact it does not
you're even gonna matter what these are
so I'm just gonna call it this X is some
tensor with one X variable and Y and see
so we're gonna use the fact that the
coppersmith Winograd tensor can be
partitioned into these three parts okay
so what will we do with this so here it
is it can be partitioned into these
three parts each term isn't exactly one
of them so when you look at the nth
power we can also look at partition it
into like which part the term came from
in each of the end components so it's a
sum over choosing like the XY or z part
for each of the end coordinates of the
tensor product of those parts and this
is again a partitioning of the terms of
the nth power of the tensor so let's
look at just one of these one of these
terms in the sub one of these some ants
so for any given one we know that we've
made one of the choices either X Y or Z
at least a third of the times so let's
say without loss of generality at least
a third of the t sub i's are equal to X
that means the tensor T 1 x dot times TN
has that most pupils us 2 to the 2/3 and
different X variables like in one one
third of the times we're multiplying by
a tensor that only has one X variable
and the rest of the times we're
multiplying by tensors that have at most
two plus two X variables so in total we
only have Q plus 2 to the 2/3 and X
variables and in particular since
monomial D generations can't increase
the number of variables that means I sub
MD of this tensor the independence of
number of this tensor is that most that
number of X variables it's that most Q
plus 2 to the 2/3 n okay so our tensor
it's a disjoint some of these different
tensors and in particular that means
that I of the tensor is less than or
equal to the sum of I of those different
components this is just because if you
had a monomial degeneration of the
tensor on the left we would all into an
independent tensor it would also give
that like that same monomial
degeneration would also degenerate each
of these terms on the right to an
independent tensor and give upper bounds
on I sub MD of all those terms so it's
less than equal to the sum over each
component of I so MD for each of those
we have the bound Q plus 2 to the 2 n
over 3
so overall since there's 3 to the end of
them we get this upper bound on I sub
see and just rearranging it shows it's
that most 2 plus 2 to the 1 minus Delta
where Delta is this thing which is
getting bigger as Q gets larger like I
promised to it yeah so it's pretty
simple and that's actually the whole
proof okay yeah so just to conclude so I
think maybe maybe these these lower
bounds you might think of them as some
negative type of result like oh maybe
it's it's hard or impossible to prove it
Omega equals 2 now but I think you can
actually view them in a positive light
also so like we give some nice
combinatorial properties like this
probability distribution lemma that then
uh nice tensors that are easier better
to analyze would have so maybe this can
help narrow in on tensors that could
help us get bit better bounds on Omega
yeah so I think it would be really nice
to look I guess Virginia alluded to this
earlier but I think we more or less know
how to extend these results to the
universal method to but but more
generally more lower bound techniques
and figuring out exactly what what types
of four approaches could improve Omega
and what types couldn't would be really
exciting yeah thanks
[Applause]
so for the group cancer you're using
some version of the Parliament is it a
views yeah yeah
so the well the most distinct way to
describe it I guess is you can show that
if if the tensor or a big power of the
tensor has a monomial degeneration to a
big independent tensor that means the
group has R or a power of the group has
big tri-colored some free sets and and
for instance using the polynomial method
they show that these things can't exist
yeah yeah yeah that's why it's harder
like I guess we've made lots of
arguments about the number of different
variables and when you when you can do
these linear combinations to bigger sets
of variables it's a bit harder to argue
about these types of things
and it's